>> Tucker: BILL MELUGIN HAS
COVERED THE BORDER MORE CLOSELY
THAN ANY REPORTER IN THE UNITED
STATES THE LAST TWO YEARS.
TODAY IN HIS ESTIMATION, THE
SINGLE LARGEST CARAVAN OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS FLOWING IN TO
THIS COUNTRY IN HIS TWO YEARS OF
WATCHING CROSSED TODAY.
HE BROKE THE STORY.
HE HAS REMARKABLE VIDEO.
BILL, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WHAT THE DID YOU SEE?
>> TUCKER, GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
YOU MENTIONED IT.
THIS WAS EASILY THE BIGGEST
GROUP WE HAVE EVER SEEN DURING
OUR 19 MONTHS OF COVERING THIS
HOMELESS CRISIS.
THEY ALL CROSSED ILLEGALLY IN
EL PASO.
THIS IS A MASSIVE CARAVAN OVER
1,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
CROSSING IN TO EL PASO LAST
NIGHT.
LOCAL MEDIA REPORTING IT WAS
POTENTIALLY UP TO 2,000 PEOPLE
AND THAT IT WAS POSSIBLY THE
BIGGEST MASS CROSSING IN THE
CITY'S HISTORY.
AS YOU LOOK AT THE VIDEO, YOU'LL
SEE WAVE AFTER WAVE OF THESE
PEOPLE WALKING ACROSS THE RIVER
AND GATHERING ON THE U.S. SIDE
OF THE RIVER WHERE THEY FORM A
SINGLE FILE LINE.
THAT LINE STRETCHES AS FAR AS
THE EYE CAN SEE.
WELL OVER 1,000 PEOPLE CROSSED
THERE.
IT WAS COLD THERE LAST NIGHT.
SO YOU'LL SEE MANY OF THEM
STARTED SETTING CAMP FIRES IN AN
EFFORT TO KEEP WARM.
CBP SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT
OVER THE LAST 24 HOURS IN THAT
SECTOR, THERE'S BEEN MORE THAN
2,400 ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
BORDER PATROL HAS 5,000 MIGRANTS
IN CUSTODY.
THEY'RE OVER WELLED AND OVER
CAPACITY.
THEY HAVE STARTED MASS RELEASES.
THEY'RE DROPPING HUNDREDS OFF AT
A TIME IN EL PASO CITY STREETS.
THE QUESTION WHERE DID THEY COME
FROM?
WE'LL SHOW YOU.
BUSSED IN WITH A MEXICAN PLUS
ESCORT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SECOND PIECE
OF VIDEO HERE.
FOX NEWS ON SEEN IN JUAREZ.
20 BUSES FILLED WITH THE
MIGRANTS RECEIVED A MEXICAN
POLICE ESCORT IN TO JUAREZ, THE
CITY OUT OF EL PASO AND DROPPED
OFF AT LOCAL SHELTERS AND NGOs
THERE.
BUT THEY DIDN'T STAY AT THE
SHELTERS.
THEY STARTED WALKING OVER TO THE
RIVER, WALKING TO THE BORDER.
THEY STARTED CROSSING IN MASS.
BIZARRE TO SEE THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT ESCORTING THEM THERE.
BACK OUT HERE LIVE, THE NUMBERS
JUST EXPLODING HERE AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH THE U.S.
BORDER PATROL CHIEF SAYING IN
THE LAST 48 HOURS, THERE'S BEEN
MORE THAN 16,000 ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS AVERAGING OUT TO 8,000
PER DA